[Music]
welcome back well with no senate
stimulus agreement in sight president
trump
took matters into his own hands and
signed four executive actions yesterday
these actions are designed to help
struggling americans get back on track
gop house leader kevin mccarthy was on
the front lines of the congressional
negotiations
he joins me now with more good morning
congressman so it's a pleasure to see
you and thank you for being here
what was the problem why couldn't the
democrats and republicans come together
on this much needed stimulus well it's
not something unusual remember
every time we've done legislation when
it comes to covid
nancy pelosi has always held it up for
own personal wish list
remember when we did the cares act she
held it up for more than a week
when thousands of people were being
unemployed
because she wanted more money for the
arts in the kennedy center
when that critical money came through
for the small businesses that went to
the employees
remember the ppp and we were running out
of money she held it up again in that
famous
video in front of her refrigerator for
ice cream that
she didn't care so thousands of more
people were laid off and now when we are
sitting here
coming forward with people unemployed
again she held it up over the issue of
thought she believed pot was more than
important
than the paychecks now what president
trump did he really showed he was the
one person in the room
that put people before politics he said
you know what
i'm going to continue to help the people
on unemployment if you're going to
continue to play these games
i'm going to take action and put america
first
instead of your own personal ambitions
so i don't understand when you say pot
why why did that
hold things up that's what happened well
that was one of the major things if you
watch in her press conferences
she the democrats passed three trillion
dollars in in their three trillion
dollar bill
it mentioned cannabis more than he
mentioned research or jobs
she would say that you had to have
continued to do that fifteen dollars an
hour extra
in the unemployment when her own
majority leader said no that wasn't a
sticking point and that should actually
be
lower president trump what did he do he
made sure those who are unemployed
continue to get extra money found common
ground
where nancy pelosi would not she would
just take that strong
position that nothing can happen unless
the the
liberal list of items she wanted and one
of those happened to be pot
wow so let's go through the president's
executive off uh
action here it's calling for four
hundred dollars a week in supplemental
unemployment and unemployed
people get they were getting the six
hundred dollars
the action also requires states to pay
for 25 percent of the 400
weekly benefit what's most important
about these executive orders congressman
that we need to understand
what are people going to feel well those
people who are unemployed right now will
continue to get their state unemployment
but they'll get that extra from the
federal government so they can continue
to pay their rent
pay their housing and move forward but
if you look at the jobs numbers it's
true that
this is the right president at the right
time bring this economy back up
the millions of more jobs every single
month moving forward
that's what we need to do get people
back to work the real challenge and the
pain here
that the democrats could not find common
ground is when it comes to the small
businesses
i think they need a little more help
when it comes to ppp or what about those
items when we want to
take that supply chain back from china
that we want to bring those businesses
back to america
we could have got tax cuts in there that
provided those
companies to come back to america or
what about the funding for the schools
that we could open them safely these are
all the things that
got hurt because the democrats wouldn't
be there these are the items that the
president
has the power to do as president and he
took those actions so those who are
unemployed
continue to get funding that nancy
pelosi has held you apostate
remember yes yeah
how will vice president former vice
president joe biden handle all of this
we are expecting that he will announce
his vp candidate in the coming weeks
certainly before the democratic
convention which is which is in a week
or a week away
what are you expecting there well he's
narrowed the field he said it'd have to
be a woman
i believe he believes it'd be a woman of
color so the field is a little narrow
and all of them have some pluses and
minuses
i mean in the latest discussions he
talks about kamala harris
a new senator from california she has
different
pluses and minuses i i'm not sure she'll
add to the ticket
remember what she said about joe biden i
mean she went after him with a vengeance
when it came to the campaign and she
never apologized for it
then if you look at susan rice
yeah susan rice is one that's very
interesting never been elected before
but what i really think what would the
american people think she is the
architect of the iran agreement
where we gave hundreds of billions of
dollars to iran and what did they do
with it
they used it on terrorists around the
around the world around the globe
her policies are not something that
america would want and i don't think she
has a good track record we've watched
her lie to the american public
numerous times but then again if joe
biden was president
during this virus we would be in worse
shape remember he was opposed to
stopping those
those airlines from china coming to
america he thought that was a bad
decision it took him a month
before he ever agreed with it
all right i know that you've talked a
lot about technology companies and
perhaps
what they're going to do going into the
election real quick we're running out of
time here but i want to get your take on
google
are they going to try to center
conservative speech
right before the election 85 days away
now
now if they're going to try they're
already doing it you watch what they did
in 2016 when they met together then
special programs
trying to bring more people out to vote
for hillary but remember
they have 90 of all searches on the
internet go through google
they determine what you see they
determine what you understand
they call the republican party of
california that we
had nazism in our ideals they believed
that this was okay
yeah i remember that they have taken
like
sites like crazy and made you they've
taken sites like breitbart and not
allowed you to see them
so they stopped traffic from going to it
they could take control of what they
said you write about google a name yeah
that i'm not already i never see that
that's right right but right for some
reason they've totally they've totally
denigrated breitbart it's true
congressman it's good to see you thank
you so much for waiting on all of this